- Everybody ready?
One, two, three..
All right, somewhere about here.
- We're gonna lay the balloon
and the basket that way,
so you can do the suit up right here.
Many years have lead up to the
flying that we're doing now.
I don't think I've ever looked forward to
anything more than this.
- Trent, I guess you're
taking care of fuel tanks?
Now I get to put all of this time and
all of this energy into
the ultimate adventure,
which is flight.
You gotta let it keep those sides out.
[String Music]
Fantastic job.
I get to have the history of
space and flying exploration,
and I get to do it in a
spacesuit that I have built.
OK, you can hand me the pressure valves.
This is hard for me to
beat as a life experience.
Thank you, reading glad co.
We're gonna put my helmet on
and pressurize, and go.
My name is Cameron Smith. I am
an Archaeology professor at
Portland State University.
And for the past eight years
I've been building my own
spacesuit.
When I was 12, my dad would
bring home eight millimeter
footage from the moon
landings, and he'd project
them on the bedroom wall.
And I would watch these alien
scenes; that was a pretty
magical thing to me.
A lot of it was about something
new; a lot of it was about
exploration-seeing something
that hadn't been seen before.
Between the ages of 10 and
14, I wrote to all of the
Apollo Astronauts. And I was
trying to get into space; I
wanted to know how. They told
me to fly for the military,
but my eyes weren't perfect.
So, that was the end of that
dream, when I was very young.
For a long time, I thought
if I were just a little
smarter, if I could be more resourceful,
then I really did think
I could go to space.
So, I thought the way that
I could get there was to
build a balloon and to
make my own space suit.
For the human body space
is a very difficult place.
In the shade it can be
minus 300 Fahrenheit.
In the sunshine it can
be plus 300 Fahrenheit.
That's hard to imagine.
For all these reasons, if
you're going into space,
you'd be well advised to wear a spacesuit.
A spacesuit is basically
a compression device.
It holds you together in
the absence of atmospheric
pressure.
It has some properties that
are going to keep you warm,
but is also doesn't keep
you too warm. It has to be
gas impermeable; it should
be flame proof, so it can't
catch fire. You're dealing
with fuels of all kinds, and
it also has to be non-stretch.
That is, you don't want it
to be ballooning up when
the suit is pressurized.
It's a fascinating challenge
to get all of those things
functioning in one environment.
All right, first pressurization
attempt with the newly
reinstalled appendix.
All right, so this is a test, keeping the
fire extinguisher armed.
Two hundred holes built for a new visor.
At 2 PSI, to be able to do that
is astounding.
It sounds mind-boggling: how
do you build a spacesuit?
Well, I started looking at
the history of the early
pressure suits in the 1930s.
People were trying to fly
to high altitudes in balloons,
and when I read their stories
and I learned exactly how
they built those suits,
and I learned that they
flew to 50 and 60,000
feet and most of them survived,
I thought surely if they
could do that with pigskin
and leather and rubber,
I can use today's materials
and do the same thing.
- OK, here we go.
- [Cameron] OK.
The basic spacesuit to
get you to orbit and back
has been on the order of a $100,000,
and weighing almost 75 pounds.
My goal has been $1,000, 5 kilos
or about 11 pounds; and
to reach 63,000 feet
above the surface of the earth.
At that altitude the only
thing that will keep me
alive in my balloon
flights is my spacesuit.
When I started all of
this, I used the cheapest
and most available things
possible to prove the design.
So, for example, for the
neck ring for the helmet,
I was using a pie tin. I've
used common plumbing ball
valves, motorcycle
batteries, aquarium pumps.
Zip ties are tremendous.
Basically I'm trying to
mount this valve on this side
so it's not going to flop around.
The least interesting way
to have done this would
be to buy a Russian space
suit on Ebay, you can do that.
But that's not fun;
that's not interesting to
just copy what somebody else has done.
I wanted to reinvent the wheel myself.
So we will be able to
reach suit pressure, which
will not come up high.
The margins for error on
this project are very slim,
and you need to be willing
to work at this through
failure after failure.
I have failed, and then
rebuilt the thing, and that
failed. And I rebuilt it
and that failed; sometimes
I was trying to fix a
technical problem for a couple
of years. But then I would
say, "I'm not gonna get
"beaten by this and try again."
OK, I'm going to start
going through a few of the
set of checklists just to
be sure we have all the
items. So we're looking at
crew gloves, and those are in
the orange case. Five, six, seven eight.
We have our pin keepers.
Now these are flying instruments, so
a little bit delicate; if
we could put these up high,
so that they're not being crushed.
I have to run this like
a small space program.
And I have to have every
checklist item theoretically
known, practically understood,
practiced, simulated
many times, and then I have
to fulfill that sequence
perfectly during the flight.
And I know that somewhere
deep in the labyrinth of the
system some little mistake
could kill me. That's a
great challenge; if I wanted
to do something easy I
would pick something easy.
But that doesn't interest me.
The difficulty intrigues
me and is a source of
vitality for my life.
This is all the paperwork
required to fly a balloon.
Somebody asked me one
time if this was a suicide
mission. I thought that
was rather stupid. If this
is a suicide mission it
is the most expensive and
longest suicide in history.
It's eight years and all of my
time and energy and passion.
So this is a very bad
way to kill yourself.
I think we have now
succeeded in building the
thousand dollar spacesuit.
Nobody will believe
me of course until I
test it and prove it in
space conditions. And it
can work, it can work.
Because there's no wind I'd
like to kinda go dead center
of the playa, and then
we'll set everything up.
And no matter which way
the wind is going we've
got.. Yeah. OK, any questions?
OK, great.
Thanks, guys.
We've gotta pull the
sides up. Watch your head.
Standby.
OK, we can prepare the suit.
Sun is coming up now.
OK, it all looks nice and
squared away we should launch.
We got a fuel quantity check done?
Just like when I was a kid,
and dad projected these
Apollo landing films, now
I'm flying a balloon; and
when I'm wearing this
suit and doing that, well
that's pretty special for me.
These are childhood dreams coming true.
Com check. Everything's
good, suit's one PSI.
I know that there'll be
a moment on the highest
flight where I'll realize
I've done what I wanted
to do and everything
works. And it might only
be 10 seconds in your life.
Altitude one thousand feet.
I really believe that when
I get to the very high
altitude and my suit
is functioning and the
temperature is right
and my altimeter reads
63,000 feet. I know that that 10 seconds
is going to be great, and
it's going to be a treasure
that I can bring home, and I
can live off that for years
no matter what calamity comes
along. It doesn't matter,
I will be able to live
on that 10 seconds of
experience maybe for the rest of my life.
That will make everything worth it.